I'm a big icecream guy.
I got a cone every night every
night. Every night you're cone
guy? You're shredded!
Take your shirt off, come on!
What's up everybody.
Welcome to Stupid Questions
with Chris DiStefano.
I'm Chris DiStefano.
This is Mark Normand.
You can check out
his Web site.
Mark Normand comedy dot com
or watch a special.
Don't be yourself
on Comedy Central dotcom.
Listen to his podcast
Tuesdays with stories.
Nailed it nailed that.
I got a lotta intro's for you.
You know more
than my parents.
You're a pope for the day.
Oh wow.
What would you now make a sin.
What would you decree as a sin.
Probably DJ'ing. Yeah.
Yeah. Yeah.
I'd get rid of DJ'ing that
just bothers me. Yeah this guy
sucks.
Yeah they make so much money.
I know. Some of them. Calvin
Harris makes 45 million a year.
What. To DJ! What is that.
I don't know.
I mean it's not an instrument.
One time I saw a DJ
using his equipment
on top of a grand piano
which is like
that's like banging a blow
up doll on top an actual woman.
Come on.
What do you think's
the absolute worst name
you could name a kid.
What's just a crap, dumb name.
What's a bad name.
I guess hemorrhoid.
Johnson is up there.
This is a true person
that existed that I knew.
OK. Her last name was Jar
OK. And her first name was
Pickel.
Come on. Not lying to you.
Wow.
I know a girl in my middle
school Shanda
last name Lear. Shanda Lear.
She's a stripper now. Stupid
names.
All right next
stupid question
we're both stand up comics here.
What's your best bombing story
or worst.
One time I did a gig at the
Comedy Cellar went pretty well.
So this guy said
Hey I work in a hedge fund.
I want to come roast my company.
So he gave me a whole rap sheet
of all his employees.
And it was heavy Stubby's
Be vicious be brutal really
kill him and I was like
All right you got it.
Get in there white tablecloth.
Embrace looks well-to-do rich
and he goes
All right. There's your podium.
You've got your list
I've got it all
and I just go into and I go
Bob we all know
you're cheating on your wife
and she's there she's like what
the fuck!
And that didn't go well.
So I move on I go
Hey Jim we all know
you're addicted to coke
and sponsors they're like
What the hell what are you
crazy.
You lied to me you know.
So he leaves and I go
Hey Jeff we all know you're gay.
His kids are there like
"I knew it Dad!"
And they all run out
and I'm bombing horribly.
I do like five more of those
none of them work you know I
get off stage
and the guys like
what the hell was that.
What was that.
That was crazy
I was like I just used the stuff
you gave me like you
blew it! you blew it and I got
no money.
Next to question
what would be the worst.
Buy one get one free sale
of all time.
Wow. Buy one get one free
What do you thinks the
worst.
Probably prostitute
because you have sex with one
prostitute
you feel the shame
you don't even want
the other one. Once you're
finished.
You're like wow this was a big
mistake and two it's like
when you go to the grocery store
hungry like aw
I was too horny
I was thinking with my dick
so my eyes are bigger
than my dick.
There was a guy in Vegas
I saw
he was like walk down the street
he goes what corner
of the tutes
on. The tutes!
He just called prostitues
"tutes"
I was like I don't know. Do I
look like a guy
who owns a prostitue
like "where are the tutes!"
Alright, you having a good time
here?
I had a blast! love it. Do
some stupid questions with Chris
DiStefano
This is what I do. Great!
You're a good host.
I got you.
I got you a gift.
I'm honored.
I can't believe it.
So I know you're
from New Orleans.
Yes.
Crawfish.
Aw come on!
these. I don't know what these
are crawfish, lobster, crab
claws.
I love it.
Well that was good right.
Yeah. This is great thank you.
Stupid Questions.
With Chris Distefano I'm Chris
Distefano.
This is Mark Normand.
Check him out.
Mark Normand comedy dot com
Tuesdays with stories
and his special "Don't Be
Yourself"